The more you try to get respect, the
less of it you will probably wind up
with. And I know that might sound weird,
so let me be more precise here.
>> [music]
>> Yes, you can absolutely learn to command
more respect, but many of the most
common ways people go about that just
lead to them getting way less of it. So,
I want to break down three of those most
common respect-killing moves, and we're
going to be using characters from the
Peaky Blinders to illustrate those,
including showing the better way from
Tommy Shelby himself. But first, we're
going to start with the first
respect-killer coming from the Digbeth
Kid. Now, for context, this is someone
who has come to Tommy looking for work.
>> No, I'm
Digbeth Kid.
>> The Dig
What are you, boxer?
>> Digbeth Kid, like Billy the Kid.
>> [snorts]
>> What are you?
>> Wait, wait. It's not a real gun.
>> So, the Digbeth Kid, as he calls
himself, comes in with a fake name and a
fake gun. He knows he's meeting Tommy
Shelby, and so he's trying to appear
dangerous, but his body language gives
him away. You can see [music] his
twitchy, prey-like movements. He
shuffles from foot to foot, he can't
decide where to look, and he holds his
hat across his body like he's afraid of
taking up too much space. We've talked
about this on the channel before, but
these herky-jerky, prey-like movements
that you might see in a squirrel
instantly signal internal unsafety. So,
to avoid this, you can maintain eye
contact, slow down your movements, and
open up your stance. And you see Tommy
doing this throughout this entire video
in comfortable settings and in
high-pressure situations.
>> Please, don't let me put a bullet in
this scum tinker's head.
>> No, he's been chosen.
>> Can the chosen one smoke?
>> But back to the kid, he is attempting to
portray the facade of a hardened
criminal because he thinks it's going to
get him a job, but the facade actually
causes a problem.
>> You ever been arrested?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah?
>> No.
>> Good. You're the first bloke we've got
on here today with no criminal record.
>> You see, the tough guy act nearly loses
him the job. It's only when he drops
that and admits he's never been arrested
that he [music] gets what he wants
because his idea of what they're looking
for is the complete opposite of what
Tommy needs. And this is just as true in
all of our lives. It can be very
tempting to change what you say or how
you act to appeal to others, especially
in job interviews or dates or when
you're talking to someone that you
admire. And in the short term, yes, it
might work out, but those facades have
gaps and eventually the gaps will get
[music] exposed. And when those cracks
show, the whole thing usually backfires.
So, the first respect sin that you want
to cut out is don't try to [music] be
what you think others want. In fact,
holding true and saying what you won't
give other people often creates more
[music] respect. This works because
people trust and respect consistency.
Whatever short terms that you gain from
morphing yourself to become what other
people want will just cost you respect
when that consistency breaks down the
line. And that brings us to the second
[music] respect issue coming from Billy
Kimber.
>> Is there any man HERE NAMED SHELBY?
I'LL SAY IT. IS THERE any man here named
Shelby?
>> Kimber enters loud and brash, and many
people think this is how you command
respect by dominating everyone else in
the room. The problem is that this
inevitably creates a combative frame
where one side wins and the other side
loses. If you do this, you're going to
either wind up surrounded by yes-men
that are down to lose all the time or in
an argument. Either way, [music] you've
got extremely fragile respect. Tommy
avoids this trap by rejecting the
combative frame.
>> I'll give these men a drink. Everyone
else go home.
>> By not reacting to the gunshot with fear
or anger and instead calmly ordering
drinks, he turns this confrontation into
a discussion. And you can follow the
same playbook when you sense someone is
trying to get a rise from you with some
sort of insult or threat. And it's a
surprisingly simple move that pulls
others into your frame. You can watch
how Tommy does it here.
>> I'm told the boss is called Tommy, and
I'm guessing that's you, cuz you're
looking me up and down like I'm a
[__] tart.
>> I want to know what you want.
>> You see, the frame of an insult or a
threat is that you need to match their
energy. You have to reply super quickly
and intensely in order to win in this
combative frame. But pausing before you
speak, [music] usually for 3 to 5
seconds, up to 10 or 15 if you need it,
will allow you to reset the frame. You
can take a breath, center yourself, and
then respond instead of react. [music]
And to be clear here, a reaction means
that you are being totally pulled into
that other person's frame. You're
allowing [music] them to set the tone
and then dictate your behavior. But a
response means that you take in what the
other person has said, but you're
maintaining your frame. You're replying
on your own terms. Now, Billy Kimber
doesn't respond. He reacts to any
perceived challenge.
>> Which one of you is the boss you're
talking to?
Which one of you is the boss?
>> I'm Mr. Kimber's advisor and accountant.
>> AND I'M THE [__] BOSS, OKAY? I AM
BILLY KIMBER. I RUN THE RACES.
>> AND here he is demonstrating what might
be termed the Joffrey rule, which is
that if you have to insist on your
status in any situation, you don't have
status.
>> I am the king.
>> Any man who must say I am the king is no
true king.
>> This highlights a key difference between
Tommy and Kimber and the types that we
encounter like that in [music] the
world. Kimber fights and argues to be
respected. Tommy never does. So many
people think that being respected means
insisting upon it all the time. You
can't let anyone get away with
disrespecting you. But there is always
going to be people who want to undermine
you, play status games, or just casually
disrespect you without even thinking
about it. If you get defensive or you
overreact, you will just come across as
insecure. [music] So when these sorts of
challenges come, it doesn't mean that
anything has gone wrong. You do not need
respect from every single person, and
you don't need to win every interaction.
Just take a breath, ignore the bait, and
maintain your frame. Which brings us to
the third issue coming [music] from
Inspector Campbell. For context here,
Campbell and Tommy are meeting to
negotiate. Now, watch how Tommy opens
this conversation.
>> I'm a businessman. I want to make my
business successful.
>> So, we are on the same side.
>> I think that absolutely could be.
>> Tommy is direct. He says what he wants
clearly, and he maintains this
directness throughout the conversation.
Contrast this with how Campbell handles
it.
>> How can we be on the same side when I
see things like this?
>> Campbell is repeatedly sarcastic. He's
condescending. He's indirect. He is
uncomfortable with the direct
aggression, so he uses
passive-aggressive comments instead.
Now, people who use this kind of
comments don't want to fully own their
hostility. So, they hide their
aggression under innocent-sounding
comments to give themselves plausible
deniability. They want to maintain power
over people without other people
realizing that they're doing it. We all
know people who play games like this,
and nothing feels more patronizing. But,
if you respond in the right way, it can
totally [music] turn the tables. So, how
does Tommy handle these sorts of
passive-aggressive comments? Well, the
same two steps that you can use. First,
Tommy responds to the superficial layer
of Campbell's underhanded remark.
>> Excuse me, I don't seem to have a pen to
write down this rather long list of
demands.
>> And this is true in real life. If
someone makes a comment that could be
interpreted as either genuine or maybe
it's sarcastic, it's a really powerful
move to respond as if it's genuine the
first time. This is another form of that
nonreactivity that we saw from Tommy
earlier. Shows that you're unaffected,
and it forces the other person to either
explain their insult or to just move
past it. But, if the indirectness
persists, you can move to step two.
>> I have what you're looking for.
I have the guns.
>> What guns?
I'm not explaining anything.
>> Wait. Wait.
>> Tommy doesn't overreact. He just walks
away. And when we want something, we can
find it really hard to do this. You see
it all the time. People work for bosses
who undermine them, or they stay with
passive-aggressive partners when it
would just be better to get up [music]
and leave. But, the moment you show that
you're willing to leave, people realize
that they have to drop the
passive-aggressiveness and engage with
you honestly, or they risk losing the
interaction altogether. You see that
happen with Campbell as he's forced to
call Tommy back to the table. I actually
broke down a similar real-life scenario
in much more detail with Robert Downey
Jr. that follows a very similar
framework. In that video, I actually
highlight four steps if you want to go
slowly through the nuances, but the key
point holds. Indirect and
passive-aggressive games will fall apart
when you first interpret charitably, and
second, refuse to play. So, what do
levels one to three have in common? They
are all trying to get respect by proving
their worth. The kid is lying to prove
that he fits in, Kimber is trying to
prove that he's in charge, and Campbell
is trying to prove that he's respectable
despite his double-dealing. [music] And
this desperation to prove themselves
actually makes us respect them less.
But, Tommy is operating at level four.
He does not have this proving energy.
He's not trying to prove that he's
dangerous, clever, or in charge. His
disinterest in proving himself to others
underlies all the behaviors that we saw
earlier, his consistency, his
non-reactivity, and his directness. He
is not trying to [music] prove his
worth. But, there is a problem here.
>> He's going to trigger the grenade, and
you're a very combustible room. You'll
blow us all to hell,
and I don't care, cuz I'm already dead.
>> [music]
>> Tommy's disinterest in proving himself
comes from his lack of self-worth. And
this emptiness shows up in his
destructive behavior, his drinking, his
violent outburst, and his relentless
ambition at the expense of the people
around him. Tommy struggles to express
himself emotionally, and he believes
that he can never find peace.
>> There's no rest for me in this world.
>> So, this is the big question. How can we
stop trying to prove ourselves without
cutting ourselves off emotionally? The
answer is by building self-respect.
[music]
And self-respect comes when who you want
to be aligns with who you are. Tommy
lost sight of that ideal self due to the
trauma that he experienced in the war.
But to build self-respect, you need to
have a clear and realistic picture of
who you want to be. Now, this might
sound simple, but you have to ask
yourself some very challenging questions
like, how does my ideal self respond to
conflict and how do I do that today? How
does my ideal self respond to the
possibility of rejection and how do I do
that today? And how does my ideal self
act in awkward social situations? And
don't answer these questions with how
you want other people to react to you.
It's about how you respond regardless of
the situation. Now, Kimber, Campbell,
and the Digbeth Kid all know who they
want to be, but they ignore the gap
between that ideal self and their actual
self. And so, they look to others for
validation. They do not realize that
external validation can only get you so
far because the truth is, you cannot
[music] outsource self-respect. It's in
the definition. Only you can build it.
So, once you have a clear idea of who
you want to be, just take one small
concrete step towards that thing. So, if
you want to be more productive, focus on
spending less time scrolling social
media. If you want to be more
disciplined, choose a small task and do
it every day for 1 month. Just start
small and then follow through. Because
whenever you deliver on a promise that
you make to yourself, you strengthen
that self-respect. And when you start
respecting yourself, people notice. They
see that you're not relying on them for
validation, that you're not shaken by
being undermined or insulted, and that
you're not terrified of rejection. And
through that, they will see that you're
not trying to get respect, and that
actually makes them much more likely to
respect you. So, if you're interested in
the fastest way that I know of to make
this stuff [music] effortless, you might
be interested in my course Charisma
University. You get full details at the
link here, but basically if you like the
YouTube channel and charisma, confidence
building respect [music] is a priority
for you, I highly encourage you to click
the link, check it out, learn more, and
maybe join. Either way, I hope that you
have enjoyed this video and I look
forward to seeing you in the next one.